A wise crack flesh,
jared,
again,
before we get into it,
just a note,
we didn't do a quick take last week
because,
well,
while the world early conspiracy was one
of our favorite episodes of the season,
we didn't really have much to add to the
discussion,
but we're back to take on season three,
episode six,
where we'll be looking at the toxic side
of our favorite adventuring duo.
I really love this episode for two
reasons.
First,
they manage to address the kind of
character development we crave in a way
that's both satisfying and the exact
opposite of what regular TV does.
And second,
they tap into some really interesting
ideas about mental health.
So fire your therapist and join me on
this quick take of rest and relaxation.
A quick recap,
rick and morty need a break from almost
dying all the time.
This was insane.
That was pure luck.
I was not in control of that situation
at all
and come to the realization that they're
burned out.
So they vacation at an alien spa and
take a mental detoxifier for a spin
while the dual fuel cleanse and
rejuvenated they leave behind the parts
they hate most about themselves.
Morning continues to live his life
without these sense of crippling self
doubt becomes the most popular kid in
school and even lands a date with
Jessica.
Meanwhile,
Rick seems like a normal human being.
Excuse me,
but this new reality is interrupted as
the toxic versions of themselves managed
to escape and turn the whole world a
weird as we praise our loving father.
July,
we made them up.
One of the cleverest aspects of this
episode is what I'm going to call anti
character development.
As we've mentioned before,
Dan Harmon is a strict adherence to his
version of Joseph Campbell's the hero's
journey.
Now,
the relevant part here is that many
stories use protagonists confronting
their shadow.
It kind of dark reflection of themselves
that they must overcome like Dr Jekyll
and Mr Hyde in terms of character
development.
This overcoming usually means arch euro
has some new insight on life,
like when a compassionate Logan
sacrifices himself battling the
murderous x 24,
overcoming his selfishness,
or when Luke Skywalker's spares darth
vader overcoming his temptation toward
the dark side.
This episode uses this structure toxic
Mourdian toxic.
Rick are quite literal shadow versions
of themselves,
but instead of overcoming their toxic
personality traits,
this episode is a journey to reunite
with their worst selves.
Excuse me.
Healthy morty is a smooth operator with
lots of friends who ultimately needs to
rediscover his self-loathing and
healthy.
Ric is a thoughtful,
super genius who needs to rediscover his
narcissism and irrational care for
morty.
If anything,
the regular kind of character
development,
normally I would come down on any kind
of disruption,
but it seems to represent a positive
change for your character is pretty
creepy,
but I also think this anti character
development serves as a pretty smart
commentary on mental health in our
society.
Rest and Rick laxation asks,
what does it mean to be mentally word
around school as you've become super
healthy?
In many ways,
this episode serves as an extended
parody of certain healthy attitudes
promoted by self help Gurus,
popular media,
and the occasional life purpose
cheerleader.
I swear they exist in La.
Focus on the good things.
Trust me.
Things are good.
In particular,
this idea that we must strive to
eliminate any thoughts that are
unpleasant or painful.
Hashtag positive vibes.
Hashtag selfcare.
Hashtag blessed Hashtag.
Sorry dot sorry.
Now there are a ton of installation
tools will tell you that being mentally
healthy means uncritically loving
yourself,
saying yes to everything,
counting your blessings and believing in
yourself,
no matter how stupid your passive income
scheme is.
However,
Rick and morty shows us that these
ideals fully embodied will make you seem
like a coked out Weirdo.
You know,
you're so quiet.
What's wrong?
Why don't you tell me about yourself?
What's the atmosphere like on Planet
Jessica?
I think one of the ideas of the show is
getting at is something sociologists,
William Davies has written about in his
book the happiness industry.
For our longtime fans,
we actually talked about this book and
our inside out video.
Demis writes about a concept he calls
compulsory happiness that in our modern
world there exists a kind of alliance
between corporations,
managers,
and advertisers to promote a definition
of mental health that ultimately serves
the capitalist society,
that we live in a kind of happiness that
involves cheerfully accepting the status
quo.
Something touched on by rick before
because I don't respect therapy.
I think it's helped a lot of people get
comfortable and start panicking,
which is a state of mind.
We value in the animals who eat this
kind of happiness also requires constant
self improvement for the sake of being a
better consumer.
Let's work off your trauma with some
urban spin yoga.
It's amazing.
You do yoga on a bike,
but you have an at risk preteen.
I think I can just blow this off.
Morning,
we see morty spouting platitudes that
seemed lifted from a Tony Robbins book.
I love drums.
I never took drum lessons.
Why?
Limitations?
We are addicted to our own limitations.
How amazing is that demanding that
everyone around him partake in his new
lifestyle?
You have to do this detox thing.
I did.
Is that an alien spa?
You go through it and when confronted
with real life problems like a scented
part of himself being trapped in hell,
his answer is,
trust me.
Things are good.
Taking that away from me,
that wouldn't be healthy.
The problem with this is that many of
the things the self help industry wants
you to erase like self doubt and sadness
are pretty important.
In the case of Morty,
it can hold you back from becoming a
full on sociopath and a sociopath.
He becomes in a scene lifted from the
wolf of Wall Street.
It looks like healthy.
Morty is at the top of his game as an
unscrupulous stockbroker,
handholds biotech million and a half at
33 with a new hot redhead to replace
Jessica.
Rick even compares him to another
sociopathic Wall Street fat cat with too
much self esteem.
Sorry,
tiny American psycho.
So what about rick?
Rick realizes some of these less
desirable parts of ourselves,
despite the pain they caused are
essential to actually being healthy.
Do the healthy thing,
and voluntarily read toxify yourself.
Jessica even tells marty good to have
you back suggesting them mortise
authentic self hating self is truly his
better self,
but my only complaint with this episode
is,
well,
it doesn't really make sense.
We're meant to believe that the
undesirable parts of a person are purged
from their being based on their own
subjective definition of toxicity.
How could that detox machine know the
difference between healthy and sick?
For everything that goes through it,
it can't.
It must be by the individual's own
definition of toxicity.
Yet healthy rig says this to morty.
I'm real proud to be your grandpa.
Morning then later claims that his
attachment to morty is irrational,
therefore toxic and allows him to
nonchalantly do this.
So is his love for morty toxic or
healthy.
Well,
for more thoughts on that,
be sure to check out the squash our very
own rick and morty podcast.
We've been breaking down every episode
of Rick and Morty and people seem to
like it.
For those of you missing a quick take on
the World Durley conspiracy,
we've even gotten episode on that.
You can find the link in the description
or almost anywhere you get your
podcasts,
itunes,
stitcher,
Google play,
soundcloud,
just to name a few and don't forget to
leave a review on itunes.
We might even read it on air.
Thanks for watching guys.